I was recently with Sharon Stone trying
to interview her and all she did was was
talk about this movie it's an epic
Masterpiece Leo's in that movie Leo has
like a fairy godmother in Hollywood and
it's you she had mentioned again a story
when they didn't really want you for
quick in the dead I really believed in
Leo you pay his salary or something yeah
because when I was producing the quick
and the dead the other producers didn't
believe in the choices I was making when
I wanted Leo they said if you want him
so much pay him out of your own salary
and I said okay will hey good
morning seems like you definitely had a
good time last night huh have you sent
her a thank you gift I don't know if I
sent her an actual physical thank you
gift but I cannot thank her enough she
was she was amazing she did that with
myself and Russell Crow at the time I
think she saw our early work they were
so mad at me by the time we started
production it's incredible she's been a
a huge champion of of of Cinema and
giving other actors opportuni so I am
very thankful